[Music]
wow
great dedication by dorsa hello everyone
i'm grand master dennis borosch and this
is insane
indian and today we're going to take a
look at
more fascinating chess from jose raul
capablanca so let's have a look so the
first game
between jose or capoblanca
is interesting because it looks tedious
many end games he plays looks
fairly tedious however
there are some little details that you
have to understand
to really grasp how couple how good he
was at this end game so let's take a
look
so the first move d4 f5
now nothing really special and what's
interesting
and that's why i kind of bring out the
openings as well
that even though capablanca was very
good at
the end game part he was also
a master tactician so the next move
would actually surprise you
if you just think oh capablanca what a
fantastic
positional and end game player he goes
e4 sacrificing a whole pawn
and in fact this popular this movie is
popular to this day
i have to take c4 and c3 knight f6
bishop g5 now i'm not going to delve
deep into
the theoretical part because that's not
really the topic
but interestingly enough the best move
here is knight c6
d5 knight e5 and bringing the knight
over however corso's
response c6 is very logical trying to
bring the queen out as this bishop
has moved away from defending that
square
bishop takes f6 e takes f6
knight takes c5 d5
knight g3
actually nothing special um if you just
look at this position
you'd think why would this game be
anyways terrible for corzo
and it's not it's actually decent very
very decent
so queen e7
and i guess that's kind of the
difference between
upcoming talents and seasoned grand
masters or world champions at that
they don't mind exchanging queens queen
e7 is sort of saying hey
i don't mind exchanging queens there's
no way you're going to beat me
and couple blank goes queenies and says
okay i'll i'll try that i'll try that
zucchini too queen takes c2
should take c2 so
if you look at this position you might
be correct in saying
wait a minute isn't capoblanca worse
here
because capoblanca does not have the
bishop pair
black does um does white have a better
structure
not really it's very symmetrical once c3
is played
maybe the only weakness that corso made
so far is f6
the spawn has moved from mature original
outpost from f7
so it just doesn't seem like a big deal
bishop d6
knight f3 castles
and at the moment um it's very hard to
believe that anything
desperate will happen to black castles
nothing spectacular like all the moves
that capablanca played so far
are okay but nothing spectacular castles
and here actually black makes a
terrible terrible strategic mistake and
this often happens
when we have this world-class player
versus an average player kind of
match-up or club player kind of match-up
here corzo gets very excited
that he could exchange the whole board
which
the excitement is understandable but
there will be ramifications he goes for
bishop g4
which is not a bad move but has the bad
idea in mind
he is going to exchange of these bishops
which were the assets of the position
which actually makes me feel that
black is maybe even better like if you
go rook e8
rook here knight d7
i do not see any reason why black
shouldn't be fine
once the knight and bishop gets out
there's just no way for rights to break
through
nor are these bishop on e2 knight on f3
and g3
is too inspiring in fact it's not
inspiring at all
but corso goes bishop g4
saying every exchange gets me closer to
a draw
but that is very very far from the truth
h3 and h3 is kind of this cheeky move
that is beloved and love to be played
what is saying please be my guest
take my knights please do it
and corso does takes takes
bishop takes knight d7
the irony of the whole thing is that
this is still completely fine for black
these pawns are kind of reducing the
scope of this bishop
so if anyone's kind of hoping to be
better it still should be black
rookie one rookie eight
but the issue is black is trying
desperately
to make the half a point instead of
trying for more
and this is one of those things that i
have to
recall from my own coach saying
if you want to have half a point you
should try for the full
wholesale point otherwise you're never
going to get that half a point
king f1 and f5
feels a little bit desperate and in fact
might be the reason
why black loses the game right now there
is
not a single way of getting inside
black's position this square is blocked
off
e4 is controlled as well possibly
if black would have been more consistent
even the simple move of king f7 would
and should
do the job just bring the king in
it's a nine game so the kings actually
become stronger
and with these important squares under
control
corza is more than likely to survive
this game
maybe even push for more because
as we might have heard fisher won plenty
of games
with a knight versus bishop in his
famous
u.s championship tournament
so king f7 would be a better choice
even if they exchange that doesn't make
any difference
to bishop g4 there's knight b6 check is
not a big deal
because black can go g6 and there are
no ways of coming through and corso
could have
a a plan of getting the knight to d6
maybe even
eventually to e4 or knight c4 and id6
in both cases black is in no danger of
losing the game
but plays f5 and
this is maybe a sign of overconfidence
saying
okay i managed to exchange everything i
wanted maybe the safest moment will be
if i could get the knight to e4
but i guess corso just didn't realize
that he just gave away this e5 square
which will prove
very very important at the end so rook
takes c8
rook takes c8 rookie one
capablanca rightfully realizes that
if the knight gets to e4
that the rook's still on the board it's
very difficult to make any progress
those rooks do control the most
important squares
where white could enter so it's
important here for white to take on e8
take rookie one because with this choice
he is going to give corso an option
are you going to keep your rook well if
you do
you let my rook invade or at least
get a control of the open file even that
wouldn't necessarily be too tragic
if rookie seven there's king f8 and the
rook won't stay there for long
same deal with rookie six king f7
and actually the rook is trapped on that
square
so rook takes c1 in this sense is again
a mistake
believing that every exchange will lead
to draw but
chess is more complicated than that not
f6
king d2 and here comes the journey of
the king
the king will walk all up
zigzag all up to e5 and
from there it'll have some pressure on
the f pawn
and a pressure and plan of going towards
d6
c7 and b7 now
is this that trivial of course not
but does this give ample winning chances
for capablanca
yes king d2
knight e4 king e3 and probably here
black realized
that pawn doesn't matter that much
because if i can go king f4
take and the king actually bolts towards
the
queen side and white is just practically
up a king
which is the most important part in the
end game i heard that the king
is considered to worth around four or
four and a half
points but i never really bought into
that kind of argument
a king is a king even if it is worth
four points if you check made it
it still is a zero for you
so i'd say it's the strongest piece but
i'd be very careful giving it a value
so knight d6 was played bishop e2
if king f f4 king f7 is in just
time to stop the invasion and black
might play g6 knight f7
smoking out the king so it's not like he
is already winning
bishop e2 move
that sort of just restricts black's
plans
so before capablanca just
went with the flow he didn't really care
too
much about the exchanges in fact
encouraged corzo to go that direction
however now he starts restricting
black species so knight c4 then again
this would transpose into a lost end
game with the king
just defeating this king on g8 not
really participating in the action
king f7 king f4 king f6
and there is a big battlefront
opening up here one of them is the e5
square if
might manage to go through that as we
already looked at
that lines the king could come on in and
white is
winning but the other question is
whether
black can go g5 and break through
that way now
capablanca as good he good of a player
he
is goes for h4 stops it
now there's no h6 because white can go
h5 and fix that g
pawn and there is no reason to worry
about it
if you go here take sticks white manages
to cross the barricade and again
this is very very difficult to hold with
black
by the way when you look at this game
when you
check it yourself notice that
it's not that corzo couldn't save this
game it's that kappa blanca posted
enough problems for him that was
insurmountable
during the game so g6
g4 again either trying to fix these
pawns on the white squares
or saying hey if you take then i can go
bishop g4 and eventually i might go
behind your pawns
h6 g5
forcing an exchange also creating a
potential target on g6
and f5 and this is actually what
capablanca does so well
he notices the potential targets in the
position
and he goes after them
and g5 is good because of that because
this pawn will be
weak in the long run king e7 g4
quite a strong move he's undermining the
f pawn
and once the f pawn is gone bishop d3 is
going to be
eyeing the g pawn right there f takes
bishop d3 a very very strong move
not even worrying about the g pawn
because the king is in firm control
there
he's going to take that knight f5
king g4 knight e4 bishop g6
now this is possible to hold
with black but in a practical game it's
much much easier to play
with white because you can combine
threats of trying to
nurse this pawn into a lady or to go
and switch over to the other side black
has to
do a dual task of trying to stop that
idea
meanwhile being conscientious of the
fact that capablanca might do a switch
around
c5 king h5 doing the plan
that i just mentioned knight e6
king h6 knight f8 up
not knight f8 in that case bishop f5
would be
very uncomfortable of course that's why
he played the king f8 that is corzo
because in that case this knight would
be dominated and it's very difficult to
deal with the g6 g7
idea this is actually
one of those formations you want to
avoid at all costs
when you're playing with the knight king
f8 bishop f5
knight g7 bishop c8 but
capablanca does the same thing again
this knight is
basically stalemated even if you go
knight e8
there is this idea of g6
if you go here then there's this nice
move of king h7 and g7
uh g8 is a big threat it doesn't even
matter you can't take the bishop because
of that and if you go here i can capture
the bomb
and that should be a winning game for
white
so bishop c8 b6 g6
and this is kind of the reason why
modern players love the bishops more
than the knight
because the bishop is very comfortable
switching
sides this knight has a difficult time
going to the other side and actually
become
useful so here the big plan for white
should be to do a sudden switch
and in that case these pawns will fall
victim for the king's attack
as this knight is not ready to block the
g pawn
and help up with the defense on the
queen side
d4 b3 not
the move that you would want to play
if you look at the color of the bishop
because you would rather have it on the
black
squares however here this one has a
function
of controlling the c4 and d3 squares
king g8 a4 so
what is sort of building this hedgehog
formation
just spiking up the d3c4 b5 squares
so there is no way of creating a pass
bomb
black's goal would be by the way to
create a passers of white ghost king g5
c4 try to exchange as many pawns as
possible
give up this knight for the g pawn and
hope that
there are not enough pawns left on the
board now it's much more difficult to do
and also the color of this
a2 pawn is identical to the color of
that
bishop on c8 which kind of increases
capoblanca's chances of winning anyways
because it's the right color even if
white is left with the a pawn it's still
a win
so b3 king g8 a4 the main concept
stopping any pawn moves this bishop has
already taken away
this idea of a6
in f8 you can see that black is just
going back and forth back and forth
bishop g4 knight e8
king here king here king h6 knight t8
bishop e2 just turn it around
and improving his pieces he decides that
this bishop on c8 might run into some
tactical ideas later
it's better to stop any advances from e2
where the bishop is from a comfortable
distance and it doesn't really have to
worry about
any attacks knight g7 bishop c4
knight e8 and once capablanca found the
ideal spot
for the bishop he ventures and goes for
the king walk
not before that he made sure that
everything's in order
and this is actually a sign of great
talent he has the patience
to maneuver around his bishop until he
finds the right spot
and then he continues on with
the decisive maneuver now of course
capablanca could have gone for the
attack this king g5
king f5 king e5 and attacking
well to be more exact g5 f5 e5
here and this way um he could have done
that earlier
but just out of prophylaxis
so just out of safety he made sure that
this bishop
and all these pawns are defended and
that's the moment he
strikes just like cause in modern times
king g5 king e7 king f5
and now again here comes the big problem
for
black the king will still need to be
around the g
pawn because if white ever manages to
push it to g7 successfully it's a win
however if your knight moves there then
you're
basically down a piece on this side of
the board
oh let me do that arrow once more
that's it not h5 bishop e2
again telling that knight to go back
if you go a knight g3 there is bishop f3
and this knight is cut off
can never go back the two
entry squares towards g7 are locked
knight g7
king d5 knight d8
king c6 king is making
all walk towards the finish line
knight g7 king b7
king d6 king takes a7 king c7
now full credit for corzo for
coming up with this creative idea of
giving up the pawn
just to lock in this king this actually
is very typical
in many end games and it is a useful
pattern to remember
you can give up a pawn just to sort of
close in that king
and get this side opposition however
white still has stronger pieces and a
way to
get the king out so it will not help
corso too much
but it is still a nice try
by the black player here 98 bishop
f3 here bishop d5
98 bishop f7 here
the king eventually gets out of that
corner and that
kind of is the beginning of the end and
he's going to
undermine the b pawn with a5
and then the c and d pawn falls so in a
couple of moves he's winning
knight to f5 a5 knight d6
king a6 takes and now
the knight has wandered off too long
and g7 wins the game
so quite a nice game by capoblanca not
that he had the advantage
from the start but gradually he created
enough targets
and weaknesses in corsa's position so he
could win it
quite astounding play honestly so the
next game i want to show
is played between capablanca and
horowitz
where again you'll see how he uses
those ideas of
actually using the structural advantage
of a position
so every end game starts
from an opening and here you'll see how
he uses
these structural weaknesses in
horowitz's position so let's have a look
so in this game capablanca goes
for the reity setup uh richard ratey who
was a fantastic fantastic and innovative
player one of the first hyper modern
players out there
he liked experimenting with knight f3
g3 ideas or both g3 and b3
now in this game we're going to see
capablanca do the same thing
we should b2 bishop f5
d3 e6 knight d2
so here white is sort of building
a little bit of a hat but it is
actually very spiky he puts pressure on
d5
and hopes to break it open with e4 later
on now not yet
because the king is still in the middle
but that is
his plan in the future bishop d6 g3
castles bishop g2 knight d7
castles queen e7
rookie 1 e5 take stakes
rook c1 so we're still in the middle
game
but there is one more thing that i want
to point out here before we
head straight to the end game these
pawns are
loose and we could also call them
somewhat hanging because there's no
support behind those pawns
and that'll actually be the reason
why capoblanc capablanca is going to get
some winning chances
rook d8 here h6 so the couple of moves
played here
are not that interesting should be six
but this is the moment where it really
gets interesting
so it seems very normal for horowitz
playing black
but now capablanca is going to
meticulously
put pressure on the dna pawns queen a1
now this looks a little bit weird
at the first side but actually it does
put a lot of pressure on the
e pawn and horowitz actually obliges
plays d4
but that again has one issue with it
the b-pawn is going to become a target
rookie c1 and this is actually a nice
thing
and i wanted to show this part as well
because capablanca
is also a fantastic tactician it's
not emphasized too much but here this
is a tactical trick there's no d takes
e3 because if rook takes c8 and
capablanca is up the exchange so
actually with this tricky move order
with rookie c1
he is gaining time rook takes c2
knight takes c2 queen d6 e3
it's just undermining this e and d pawns
and creating a weakness
d takes knight takes e3 knight g4
take sticks queen c3
rookie 8 knight e1 b6
so this is the position that i wanted to
reach
um seemingly it's very even
but compared to black's pieces
white is much much more organized
the knight is defending the only
weakness that capablanca has
and the bishop is just stronger than its
counterpart
on g4 which kind of strikes into
nothingness like there's
nothing to be targeted over here and
there's no more e2 pawn
to really attack also the knight
and bishop apart from like the bishop is
not really good but the knight at least
is defending the e
pawn so clearly here in this position
horvitz's best piece is the queen
and the first thing that capoblanca does
is to exchange it off between c6
we take c6 rook takes c6
now there is the rule when we talk about
weaknesses of two
two like two weaknesses in a position
here there's plenty of weaknesses in
black's position
so why should be able to get ample
winning chances
one of the weaknesses here is the a pawn
and the e5 pawn now the e5 pawn is
harder to get to
so there'll still be a lot of fight for
that square
that pawn is well defended however the a
pawn
is weak and it is less likely
like the a pawn is less likely to be
defended
well enough rook d8 rook c7
again immediately going after the
weakest link
a5 there's really no other way
bishop d5 so
we started off with the position with
sort of a slight advantage
for capablanca but you can
feel the pressure right now and the
advantage is sort of growing
now white has a rook on the seventh
there is a rook on the seventh there's
some threats
on the f7 square and this bishop
now is sort of tying that down that
night you can't move that knight because
the f7 pawn would fall
so that means that horvitz needs to
untangle very quickly
unless he's giving up king f8
f3 just making sure there's no bishop e2
bishop f5 bishop c4
now this might strike you as something
new and
different but if you just recall the
previous game
where capoblanca faced corzo in that
very symmetrical and dry end game he
makes sure that all of his pieces
are well coordinated and that they're
ready
to sort of take the second step
bishop c4 is that kind of move he's not
getting into the action
until he is sure that his pawns are
defended
still knight c5 wouldn't work this f7
pawn
needs a defense now bishop c4 is a good
move
because it keeps horowitz guessing
and gives horowitz the option to go
astray
there's plenty of ways of playing this
position you could go bishop g6
you could go f6 now if you go bishop g6
your bishop would be off sides and not
really participating in the
defense anymore if you go f6 instead
you are sort of
creating targets over e7 f7 and g7 and
the king
will be cut off so with this bishop c4
not only did he strengthen his situation
but he also kind of gave an opportunity
for black to go wrong king e7
bishop b5 slowly slowly strengthening
the grip
and putting pressure on that knight
bishop e6
knight g2
now capoblanca realized the rook is
ideal on the
c file it's much better than this rook
which has
no pressure and no say on that file
the bishop is pressing this knight
what's not
playing well it's clearly the knight on
e1
so if possible he'd like to activate it
via knight t1
knight e1 knight g2 knight e3 and knight
c4
going after these two weaknesses
these two weaknesses which makes this
quite a good plan so it goes knight g2
this is the plan
this is the big plan
and now porvitz is in trouble
rook b8 knight e3 right is heading
towards c4
king d8 and rook
a7 and i really love this move of rook
a7
it sort of sort of says hey
i've already got the control on the
seventh rank
i should be doing quite well here
i'm not going to leave the seventh rank
unless you work hard
to get me out of there and just notice
even if black plays a random move now
knight c4 would show up on the board
and you can't even take because there's
rook d7
here and b takes c4 winning the piece
and probably the game
why is this such a bad news
well if white's next move which is
quite a simple move is that strong that
means that
black is just in the deep trouble rook
c8
knight c4 c7 so horowitz is desperately
trying to get rid of that rook
but will capablanca oblige
no he's not going to exchange it off in
fact goes rook a6
which does look a little bit bizarre
but he's saying that the b pawn is just
too weak and eventually
after some takes on d7 it will fall
so black is forced to take
d takes and
now there is still this big threat of
taking and rook takes a b6
however there is another rule of thumb
to follow when you get a good position
and probably
capoblanca was familiar with that
anytime you start exchanging to thin
material
you're sort of loosening your grip of
the position
if white after king c8
would take on d7 then
he'd give up his very very strong bishop
on
b5 for a terrible knight that was
basically condemned to defend this
square
after rook takes there's this check or
even rook d2
giving and getting some counter play for
that pawn
now does this necessarily mean this is
not an option for capablanca not at all
i mean this could be played as well
but it's definitely inferior to the move
of rookie a
check saying hey your knight is so bad
i'd like you to have it
and once you sort of exchanged off your
powerful bishop
on e6 to my knight now i think
my job is done i don't need my rook on
a6 no more
that's that was the only reason i had it
there and now i'm going to
look for greener pastures king b7
rook g8 g6
rookie eight again
capablanca is in no rush to hunt down
pawns
he is not trying to go for example with
g4
and then this h pawn what he doesn't
want to
do is give
horowitz the momentum to untangle
g4 could potentially give a moment to
untangle maybe something like
knight f6 here and e4
not necessarily saving the game but
actually giving a bit of hope
because this knight from a terrible
square got to f6
and actually has some threats which he
didn't have
before so that makes rookie 8 such a
strong move here
because it says no i don't really care
about winning material as long as your
pieces
cannot move this is not even just going
to pursue them
and horvitz's next move is basically
just going to admit that yeah you're
right i can't do anything
and i'd rather give up a pawn for free
just let me go
just make make make me
live a better life than that if f6 by
the way
over defending there's rookie six and
after bishop d7
capablanca's rook will go full pac-man
on the f6 g6 and h6 pawns
which is completely hopeless of course
for the black player
rookie 8 so horowitz decides to go
knight c5
rook takes e5 and in this sense
capablanco was right
pressure helped him win the position
because he didn't need to
go after those pawns now the next move
for
horowitz is still kind of desperation
but it's important to see
how capoblanco wins this position even
when it is
quote-unquote completely winning
completely winning because he's up
and has much better pieces
bishop e8 again pestering those pawns on
f7 and
g6 here bishop b5
back you might be wondering
okay so does capablanca have no idea
what's going on
no he knows what's going on but he is in
no hurry
of a showing his intentions b
kind of feel or show that he's nervous
at all
he just actually repeats i'm going to
show that again
he repeats the position just
to show dominance and this is the
psychological part of chess
he kind of repeats the position saying
there is so much potential in my game
that i can repeat anytime i'd like and
you will have to oblige
and now he goes king f2 after he gained
time
i mean they played a couple of moves um
and now this is actually
winning and you know he has the winning
position
plus the psychological advantage
like he milks everything that he can in
this game of chess
king c8 f4 just trying to go f5
creating more targets
king d8 king e3 yet he's no in no rush
so he brings up his king puts these
pawns on dark squares
which is what you should do if you have
a white square bishop
king e7 rook d5
so yet again capoblanca is going for
domination he is not trying to
force the win so he's not trying to find
like an easy way to end the game quickly
he just enjoys the pressure and
slowly slowly outplays horror bits
f5 of course
he had an idea in mind if he wouldn't
have had a different idea in mind he
probably would have played something
like f5
and this should be winning as well but
he decides that
hey i do not need to play on the side
where
each of us have three three pawns i
could just play on the side
where i have a majority and an extra
pawn so he goes for a3
goes for this b4 idea
knight c5 b4
take 6 knight e6
rook d3
why did capablanca go rook d3
well the rook has done its job
there's no way of getting this rook on
the default so this
rook is not a big danger but you have to
look for a new target and that new
target is
on b6 so he's going for that with this
maneuver
or at least hinting at it rook a7
not allowing this maneuver for a3 rook
a6
h4 note that
just like in the previous game he
tries to make sure that these pawns stay
on white squares
and horowitz plays this move of h5 which
is very dangerous
because if this bishop ever gets behind
them
he's just going to pick up all those
pawns
bishop c6 just activating the bishop
preparing to exchange the bishop for the
knight as well
if that exchange happens there's a
technically winning
game rook c7 bishop d5
and seeing that bishop takes e6 is
threatened he goes for night of fate
king d4 this is an end game so you bring
in
your king as capoblanca does so with
king f2 king e3 and king d4
king v6 rook a3 finally he gets his
maneuver in
and that is sort of the beginning of the
end in this game
and what we've seen from almost the
middle game
once he played queen c6 he never really
let go
all through from that moment
he had the control of the game and had
the control of the most important
squares
now this bishop is dominating this
knight on f8
this rook is dominating this rook and
after this move
there'll be c5 break happening with all
these pawns
probably falling to that rook's attack
so here now horowitz is collapsing
goes for knight e6 and
surprisingly enough like ah even i would
be tempted
to capture this knight but he says no
this bishop on d5 is just too strong i'm
not going to
give that to you
probably that is also easily winning but
he says
no i make a statement i have a good
piece
your piece is much worse than mine not
exchanging it
king d3 knight f8 rook
a8 and this is actually a wonderful game
by capablanca here horvitz resign
rightfully so because
eventually he's just going to run out of
moves or run out of
pawns so
i'm really happy that i could show you
this game
where sort of said
i prefer real
competent pieces and strong piece play
instead of material so
i hope that you enjoyed this lecture
on domination in the end games
and how to win and even end game that
can only capablanca do
thank you so much have a good night
[Music]
you